beh
tredici anni fa feci
come si diventa uomo sì lo so di solito
a google si fanno domande un po più
specifiche tipo come si prepara la
maionese e che in realtà ero alla
ricerca di me stesso e dopo dieci anni
di eroina capì che non era proprio
quella la strada giusta
ho avuto per dieci anni una identità
chimica ed ero alla ricerca della mia
vera identità e un motore di ricerca
poteva saperne più di me
pensate a come ero messo ero simona
prima singh
sin dai tempi dell'asilo dovuto
combattere contro il grembiulino rosa la
monetina nei capelli
gli orecchini fino a che a 12 anni con
tutto il mio coraggio ho comunicato al
mondo intero che non avrei mai più
indossato abiti femminili
forse vi starete chiedendo ma poi alla
fine google
cosa ti ha risposto bene ve lo dico
avevo 28 anni quel giorno e oltre a di
imbattermi in una pagina illustrata di
come diventare veri uomini in 19 paesi
google mi diede le prime informazioni
per cambiare sesso e poi l'ho fatto la
chirurgia mi ha dato la possibilità di
guardarmi allo specchio e di
riconoscermi il mio dentro e il mio
fuori finalmente coincidevano
ero nel corpo che ho sempre sentito mio
potevo fare i miei passi nel mondo
finalmente senza più nascondermi
allora ero finalmente diventato un uomo
non bastò a me non è bastato sapere ci
sono alcune cose che sfuggono ad un
motore di ricerca il cambiamento fisico
è fatto di tante tappe accompagnate da
momenti diversi emozionali confusione
paura dolore ansia sofferenza nella
discriminazione e poi forza coraggio
riconoscimento orgoglio l'ultima tappa
mi mancava io continuavo a nascondermi
stavolta come simone perché mi
vergognavo del mio passato
ci sono momenti in cui come questo che
sono molto emozionato e cercherò di
andare alla media
la mia domanda era ma allora come si
diventa uomo come si diventa un uomo in
una società che ci vuole disumanizzare
in giro di un anno perso entrambi i miei
genitori
forse si diventa un uomo con contatto
diretto con la morte pensare da allora
inizia a farmi una domanda che ripetevo
spesso come un mantra se sapessi di
morire tra qualche mese
farei quello che sto facendo la maggior
parte delle volte la risposta era no e
allora lascia tutto lascia il lavoro la
casa la città per trasferirmi in un
bosco per nove mesi giusto il tempo di
parto ritmi forse si diventa un uomo
superando la paura di uscire dai solchi
noti la paura mi confidava
nell'impotenza nell'immobilità ed io
avevo fatto tutto questo per non essere
padrone della mia vita
fedele a me stesso così inizia
l'ennesimo cambiamento ci sono molte
cose in un bosco che ti fanno pensare
nonostante le zanzare camminavo ore i
luoghi solitari ed ero sereno come non
lo era mai stato perché l'unica cosa a
cui pensavo era dove mettere i piedi nel
bosco imparato una cosa importante
perché camminare è un po come camminare
nell'ignoto scoprì la saggezza
dell'incertezza prima volevo controllare
tutto
le mie relazioni e lavoro i tempi di
spazi poi ho capito che è un'illusione
la vita imprevedibile e allora mi sono
lasciato andare come fanno gli uccelli
che vivono al di sopra di tutto come
fanno gli insetti che si occupano non si
preoccupano
come fanno gli animali la maggior parte
del tempo lo passano in silenzio a
contatto con loro stessi guardano il
mondo quasi in contemplazione
si molti di noi la mattina appena svegli
contemplano il caffè però non è proprio
la stessa cosa
imparai a farlo anch'io contemplava una
montagna un lago un albero e ne
assorbivo la quiete e in quei momenti
per la prima volta il chiacchiericcio
continuo della mia mente si fermava e in
quei momenti
io iniziai a conoscere simone di
scoprire le cose interessanti su di me
ero bravo in un arte l'arte di adattarmi
velocemente ai cambiamenti di fruire con
la vita
scoprii un'emozione nuova che non
conoscevo la gioia conoscevo la
sofferenza tristezza
conoscevo la felicità erano sempre
scaturite da qualcosa di esterno
la gioia è un'emozione intima non
dipende da nulla e ti dà tanta forza
in quel momento mi sentii in armonia con
tutto io che mi sono sempre sentito
disarmonico quel sentivo che stava
cambiando qualcosa dentro di me un po è
sentito che ti stava cambiando la mia
frequenza un po come si fa con la radio
il segnale radio è il mio stare al mondo
e prima era un segnale gracchiato in
quei mesi ho iniziato a sentire sempre
più chiaro limpido reale
ero incredibilmente secolo prima
credendo di vedere ma vedevo solo in
modo limitato e automatico certo per
qualcuno sarei potuto sembrare pazzo
lasciare tutto un uomo in crisi senza
casa lavoro famiglia
ebbene quella crisi è stato il più
grande dono che la vita mi abbia fatto
perché mi ha costretto a conoscere me
stesso e da quell'esperienza è dato un
film documentario e da quell'esperienza
è nato il mio orgoglio viene sempre data
una possibilità a chiunque voglia
ritrovare se stesso superare le paure
andare verso la felicità e io penso che
sia lo scopo più
mobile che un essere umano possa
desiderare
noi ci fidiamo più di un datore di
lavoro che nella vita ci fidiamo più di
una compagna il piano per sempre sta qui
per sempre e della vita almeno non sto
più alla ricerca come prima pensando
starò bene quando avrò incontrato la
donna della mia vita
starò bene quando farò il lavoro della
mia vita che mette mi dicevo starò bene
quando avrò la casa della mia vita la
macchina della mia vita e nello stemma
che preme è che la tua vita sta qua non
sta dentro tutta sta roba
no no
poi si va avanti poi si arriva
sicuramente si arriva la guardia in
pratica poi io un giorno mi sono
ritrovato e non so ancora come ho fatto